BARBARA IMPERIALI:
What I'm going
to do first of all for today,
the bulk of today's lecture
will be on HIV
and Ebola viruses,
with more time spent on HIV
because it's potentially
one of the mechanistically best
understood of the retroviruses.
And it also has offered
numerous opportunities
for therapeutic intervention.
And there are a lot
of themes and terms
that I can bring up as I talk
to you about the HIV virus,
because it's just a great
exemplar of the viruses.
OK.
So HIV is what is
known as a retrovirus.
So that sort of designates
that there's something working
backwards in this retrovirus.
Based on its number in the
Baltimore Classification,
it is the most recently
identified mechanism
of viruses.
HIV stands for Human
Immunodeficiency Virus.
And when you hear
the term HIV, you'll
often hear HIV/AIDS where the
AIDS part stands for Acquired
Immunodeficiency Syndrome.
So what you can start
to tell about the name--
why am I hunching down--
is there's something related to
the immune system with respect
to this virus.
And in particular, it is
that this virus targets,
very specifically, a
population of the cells that
are critical in immunity.
And when the virus
attacks those cells,
the person infected with the
virus becomes immunodeficit.
So I've talked to you
about different viruses.
Some go to the liver.
Some go for other organs.
So like the liver,
the viruses that
really cause a
deficiency in liver
function, but this one is
very specifically deficiencies
in immune function.
And it has been a tremendous
challenge developing vaccines
against HIV/AIDS because of the
problem with the immune system.
The other thing that I mentioned
to you in the last class
was that HIV is often
found co-infecting
with TB patients, people with
those microbial infections.
And that's because the
immunodeficiency makes you more
susceptible to tuberculosis.
And oftentimes
there's a co-infection
with the two diseases.
And it makes the people
with TB really even
less able to combat
the TB infection.
So that is really what gets
a lot of the TB patients.
So that's an important
aspect to know.
And it's also an
important aspect
to be aware of when treating
people for any infection
is if there's an HIV
component, the body
is much less able to
deal with mounting
an immune response
because of the fact
that the immune
cells are targeted.
So HIV is an envelope virus.
That means it has a
membrane around it.
It is this sort
of peculiar shape
where the outside of
the membrane is coated--
the outside of the virus
is coated with membrane.
And then stuck in that membrane
are particular proteins
that are very critical
for interaction
with the human host cells.
So these are often
termed GP proteins.
And the one very
important one is GP140.
And that GP stands
for glycoprotein.
Now, an important aspect,
remember, of virus lifestyle
is that they
basically exploit all
of the human cellular
machinery for their benefit
to make their proteins for all
of the basic needs of a cell.
So these glycoproteins
look like the glycoproteins
that are made by
humans, because they're
being made by the
same machinery that we
would make the glycoproteins.
In bacteria, when we
talked about them,
it's a different machinery
that glycoproteins
and glycoconjugates
look different.
But in HIV, the glycoproteins
look like our glycoproteins.
And therefore, you
could more or less
consider the HIV virus particle
to be coated with things
that look sort of human.
So that's a kind of
decoy to the human system
anyway with respect to
recognizing a foreign entity.
So often the glycans
there serve as decoys
to make the human body
think, well, there's
nothing wrong here.
Now within the
virus, there is RNA.
And it's single-stranded
but negative strand RNA,
so that's what puts it into--
Sorry.
Positive strand.
Positive.
So what puts it into
a separate category
is the fact that the genetic
material in the retroviruses
is single-stranded RNA and
it's the positive strand.
So far we've talked
about two other types
of virus mechanisms--
the double-stranded
DNA-- remember
that was as an example.
That was smallpox--
and we've also
talked about the single-stranded
RNA negative strand.
And our best example there
was the influenza virus,
which is a segmented genome.
What you'll learn
about HIV is that it
has a non-segmented genome.
Meaning that this strand
of RNA is one continuous
strand rather than
separate pieces
as we saw in the
influenza virus, which
was the last example at
the end of the last class.
Now, let me just
take a quick look.
So every virion, that would
be a single viral particle,
therefore will contain
within its structure the RNA.
And it will also contain two
copies of a particular enzyme
that are absolutely critical.
When the virus infects
a cell, there's
no time for it to make anything.
It needs a particular
enzyme to get
going with replicating
that initial strand of RNA
to start to come to make a DNA,
double-stranded DNA copy of it,
and then make a messenger RNA.
So the enzyme that's
important and there
are two copies of an enzyme
known as reverse transcriptase.
So basically, the virus
structure is fairly simple.
There's a capsid
inside with the RNA
plus the reverse transcriptase
that I'm just showing
as a filled circle here.
And then surrounding the
virion is a membrane bilayer
with GP proteins stuck into
that membrane bilayer that
are going to be
important when one
starts to think about the
infectivity by the virus.
All right.
There's a second glycoprotein
that's also important,
which is known as GP41.
And these are very specifically
part of this complex,
but associated with the GP140.
All right.
So now let's take a
look at the virus life--
or details of this virus.
But first of all, I want you
to take a look at T-cells.
You've heard a
lot about T-cells.
They're a major component
of the immune system.
So I'm going to home
you right in on what
the virus, the virion,
recognizes on T-cells
and what makes it
such a disaster
for the human immune system.
OK.
So here are typical
T-cell receptors
on the surface of T-cells.
Just as a recap, I want you
to remember T-cells produce
unique antigen binding
proteins that are
put onto the T-cell surface.
And they provide
cell-mediated immunity
by destroying antigens
such as viruses.
But what the HIV virus
does is it really
homes in on the cell-surface
receptors of the T-cells,
specifically the HIV virus
recognizes the CD4 receptor,
which is a glycoprotein on
the surface of some T-cells
that are designated as
CD4 positive T-cells.
So if you have
circulating T-cells,
that would be the first place
where the HIV virus attaches
to the T-cell to
cause infectivity,
thus debilitating
the ability to mount
the type of immune responses
that T-cells are involved in.
So it's very important
to now understand
why the physiology of
this virus is to knock out
the thing that's
there to protect us
from foreign antigens,
which makes it so serious.
Now, HIV first started to
emerge in the early '80s.
It was more or less designated
as a death sentence.
As you may be aware,
HIV circulated
around the gay community
in the San Francisco area
very rapidly.
But it then became
incredibly widespread.
There's a possibility
that the jump
of the virus from primates
to humans, the virus
might have originated in Africa.
There's a lot of work done
on the origin of this virus,
but it sort of came
out of nowhere.
It was something that was
unexpected, unanticipated,
and hitting people
just like a cannonball.
And it was literally a
death sentence early on.
As the mechanism of the
virus became understood,
a number of strategies could
be put in place with respect
to antiviral therapeutics to
target this particular virus.
And what we will see
is the four types
of targets that have
been named as targets
for therapeutic agents, why
they work, how they work.
And we'll see the mechanisms
of those as to how
they pertain to the HIV virus.
And we'll talk about things
like combination therapies.
So early on, there
was really nothing.
Gradually early, therapeutic
approaches started to emerge,
but they were
devastating treatments
because the drugs were so
poor against the HIV virus,
people were taking massive
handfuls of medications a day
to try to stay
ahead of the virus.
As time has progressed,
these therapeutic agents
have been improved and improved.
And now they're relatively
simple therapeutic agents
where you don't have to
take massive doses of fairly
non-specific therapeutic agents.
But they're quite
sort of workable.
The problem is,
and you'll see why,
people have to take these
therapeutic agents for life.
Once cells are
infected with HIV,
there will always
be a population
of the virus genetic
material in the human genome.
So you can't just say,
I feel way better,
not taking these drugs anymore,
because there is the chance
that in some repository
in some of your cells
the virus genetic
material is still there.
And you'll see which enzymes in
HIV are responsible for that.
OK?
So let's take a look
here at the Group VI
retrovirus named HIV/AIDS.
In 2015, there were 37
million people infected.
Nowhere near enough in
treatment, about half
of those in treatment.
And about 1.2 million deaths.
This may account also for
people coinfected with TB.
I mentioned to you
when we started
talking about
infectious disease,
I really encourage you to
go to the NIAID website.
There is tons of really
interesting information,
not just from a
clinical perspective
but from a mechanistic
perspective,
from a treatment perspective.
There's really important things.
So I really encourage
you if you are
interested in infectious
disease, the National
Institute of Allergies and
Infectious Diseases Component
of the NIH is the one
responsible for all
the research on
infectious disease.
And in fact, for
many, many years
during the crisis
with HIV, there
were special earmarked
funds for any research
towards the development
of therapeutic agents.
So what happens?
How does this virus,
this little particle
that I've shown you here--
I should really show
you this is the capsid.
And I should really show you
the membrane a little bit more
encircling that with
the capsid inside.
So the cartoon that you see
on the screen is more correct.
So here's the virion particle.
It has inside it the
capsid that includes
the single-stranded RNA.
It only needs to code
for very few proteins,
remember, because the virus
just exploits everything
else from the human host.
And GP120-- sorry for that
typo, please correct that.
And GP120 is displayed on
the surface of the virion.
And in fact, it's
GP120 that interacts
with the CD4 receptor on
the surface of a target host
cell, a T-cell.
Now there is a second receptor
that's quite important.
It was not discovered
until quite a bit later on.
It's designated
as the coreceptor.
And the interaction of the
virion with the host cell
is only good when there's
both the CD4 receptor
plus the coreceptor.
And this was found through
careful biology that
realized there was
another critical component
for the infectious disease.
And that is designated as
the CCR5 receptor or CXCR4
receptor.
So both receptors on
the surface, the virus
has evolved or selected
out, to recognize
cells that have both of
those types of receptors
on the surface which ends
up making them very targeted
towards the T-cells.
Once that association
occurs, then
becomes the process of fusion.
So remember, I told you that
large things can get into cells
by merging a membrane
with the membrane
on the surface of the cell.
So what is happening as those
two receptors are engaged
is the virus membrane is coming
close to the host cell membrane
and starting to fuse
through the action of GP120
along with the CD4
receptor and coreceptor.
And I'm going to
show you a movie that
shows that part of the
fusion, because it's really
cool to see it in action.
Once that fusion occurs,
the virus membrane
actually just merges with the
remainder of the host cell
membrane.
And you drop that capsid into
the cell, which then becomes
on packaged to release the
single-stranded RNA that's
the contents of that.
And what's important to know--
whoops going backwards--
is that the minute the
single-stranded RNA
gets into the cell, that
needs to be processed.
But it needs to be processed
with an enzyme that is
completely unique to the virus.
And that's the
reverse transcriptase.
Without the reverse
transcriptase being there,
it's just RNA that's just going
to get chewed up in the cell.
So what reverse transcriptase
does it reverse transcribes RNA
into DNA.
So that gets you on the track
to the infectious process.
In the absence of RT,
you don't get there.
You're not able to make
a DNA copy to then make
a copy of the RNA and so on.
So reverse
transcriptase, that is
why the reverse transcriptase
has to be delivered along
with the virus.
It can't be just a virus
with the genetic material.
It's got to have this
particular enzyme with it.
So reverse transcriptase is
responsible for converting RNA
into DNA.
And as you all know, that
is not the usual direction
with respect to
the central dogma.
We're always talking
about DNA to RNA.
But you've also heard
throughout the course,
how handy this reverse
transcriptase is material is.
When we talk about arrays
and loads of biotechnology,
using reverse transcriptase
is super valuable.
Let's say, for example, we
don't want to sequence a genome,
we want to look at the
transcriptome, the part
of the genome that's really
important for being translated
into proteins.
What we do is we collect
the transcriptome
but reverse transcribe
it into DNA,
which is a much more
stable, tractable material
for sequencing and
so on and so forth.
So RT has become kind of
a gift to biotechnology
and biological research.
And it was inspired from
the RT in the HIV virus.
So that's very important.
So the reverse
transcriptase, then,
makes a DNA copy of the RNA.
And then a second
complementary copy
of that DNA is made to make
double-stranded DNA which
represents the viral
genome, but in the format
of a double-stranded DNA.
That DNA can be, then, taken--
here's the fun part.
That DNA is actually, then,
taken into the nucleus
and it's zippered in
to the host genome
by an enzyme known as integrase.
So it's not that you
have this virus junk
and then you send
it back out again
with the mature
particles, you actually
put this in the permanent copy
of your DNA in the nucleus.
And that is why people don't
get cured from HIV/AIDS.
They have to take treatment
for the rest of their life,
because that DNA is permanently
in the copy of your genome
that gets replicated every time
your cells divide and so on.
So you can understand the
seriousness of that event.
So that gets taken
into the genome.
But also when it's time
to make new virions,
the DNA is transcribed
into messenger RNA.
The messenger RNA
leaves the nucleus,
gets translated into proteins.
And those proteins
form the basis
of the new virion particles.
Now, I mentioned
somewhere here that it
is a non-segmented genome.
So initially, the messenger
RNA is a single segment
that then gets translated into
a single segment of protein,
which is known as a polyprotein.
So there are no stops between
the various genes encoding
frames within the messenger RNA.
So that gets transcribed
by the host machinery
straight into a polyprotein
that's all glued together
in a single long piece.
But then there is another
important HIV enzyme,
the protease, that chops those
portions of the polyprotein
up into useful and
usable portions.
So you also need the
protease readily available
rapidly to start dicing up the
polyprotein into usable protein
segments for the
new virus assembly.
So let's take a look
here what happens.
The messenger
leaves the nucleus.
You make a polyprotein that gets
digested into protein segments.
And then everything accumulates
at the inside surface
of the membrane and starts
budding off the virion.
When it's first budded off,
it's not really ready to go.
It's not intact.
It has to develop a
little bit further
to become a mature
virion moving forward
to go infect another cell.
So the initial stage, that
budded stage, of the virion
is not completely
competent to go infect.
And in fact, there
has been some thoughts
about can you ensure that the
immature virion doesn't develop
into the mature virion,
because that would be one
way of targeting the system.
OK.
So there are a few
different pieces--
the reverse transcriptase,
the integrase, the protease,
and then, finally--
these are all critical
processes that
have been the targets
of therapeutic agents.
They are molecular
targets, such as enzymes.
And we know how to address
enzymes with inhibitors.
And one last feature
of the virus life cycle
that has been focused on
respect to therapeutics
is the viral fusion.
So there have also been
efforts at a molecular level
to try to inhibit this process
where your virus particle docks
down on the cell and
somehow the membranes fuse
and then the virus dumps
its contents into the cell.
OK.
This is just sort of a quick
sort of more beautiful view.
But in a minute, I'm
going to show you a video.
But I thought it was kind
of nice because it really
allows you to look at the
different steps in the virus
life cycle--
recognition, fusion, delivery,
making the double-stranded DNA,
integrated the DNA
into the genome,
and making new viral proteins.
So those steps,
they're pretty logical.
It's just like step one,
got to find my target.
Step two, I've got to
stick to my target.
Step three, I've got to
deliver my genomic content
into my target and so on.
So I don't want you
to think this is
a bunch of steps to memorize.
They all sort of make sense in
a logical progression of events
to make the virus be able to go
all the way through to budding
off new, immature, and
then mature virions.
And so as I
mentioned over there,
these are the four
targets that I'm
going to describe
to you with respect
to therapeutic development.
And this is where
they all work--
the fusion early on, the
reverse transcriptase
taking that single-stranded
RNA to a DNA copy,
the integrase which zips
the genomic material
into the genome, and the
protease that cleaves up
the long polyprotein to make
mature pieces of protein that
are part of the virus.
OK.
So let's talk first of
all about viral fusion.
And as I mentioned, when
I get to showing you--
it's a really beautiful
video from the Howard Hughes
Institute that really
shows the fusion very well.
But I want to describe
the fusion to you
at a molecular level.
And then later, you'll see it
a little bit more real life.
So what I said to you is
that GP120 and GP41, which
are these proteins that are
in the surface of the envelope
then recognize the coreceptor
and CD41 and form a complex.
So it's a complex that
involves what's on the virus.
It's actually in a
trimeric structure
with the two receptors
that are on the host cell.
And they form a
pretty close union.
And then what
happens is there are
a series of events that tug
the two membranes together,
mechanically linked to
conformational changes
of the protein, and basically
splosh the two membranes
together for a fusion event.
So it's through the
confirmational dynamics
of that large complex
happening in sequence
after the first interactions
that get you to a fusion event.
So these initially
look like this,
but then they start
changing their shape,
and making a fusion event.
So you could look at
it as, initially, you
have the complex formed,
but then, later on, there's
been a twisting
of the structures,
the large macromolecular
structures
to fuse the membranes.
So for quite a few years--
and I don't think it
was the most successful
of the approaches with
respect to therapeutics--
people thought that maybe you
could inhibit the interaction
between GP120 and
those receptors
with small molecules that
might inhibit the progress
through the fusion process.
So that was deemed
a viable target.
It's not the same
as an enzyme target,
but it's definitely a critical
point in viral infections.
And what was made
were short peptides
that might stabilize
this complex
and avoid the structure
moving forward
to the fusion-related complex.
So that was one sort
of series of events.
So those peptides were
designated a C-peptide.
They would bind to
this portion up here
that's pointed to with
the N. They'd stick
and they'd basically
jam the cogs.
They'd stopped that event
occurring by binding
quite tightly to part
of the fusion complex.
OK?
The drugs, the therapeutic
agents, in that case
were peptidic, kind of large.
They don't diffuse into cells,
but that's not a problem
because this target
is outside the cell.
So there's no need for that to
get into cells for its effect.
All of the other therapeutic
agents I'll describe to you
are molecules that need
to get into cells in order
to do their job.
But this particular strategy
didn't involve that.
Which was why it was
fairly attractive early on,
because it was a very different
target from the others.
So the next step I
want to describe to you
is inhibition of
reserve transcriptase.
So this is a RNA-dependent
DNA polymerase.
OK?
So different from the
other DNA polymerases.
We have DNA-dependent
DNA polymerases,
but we don't have the
RNA-dependent ones.
And so the types of strategies
that were used initially
was to use types of
analogs of the nucleosides
that will be used
in polymerization.
So the reverse transcriptase,
the first types of targets--
what's going on down there--
the first types of targets
were nucleoside
analogs because they
can inhibit the polymerization.
And you're going to realize you
know quite a bit about these
when we first look
at the structure.
So I'm going to
describe to you what are
known as nucleoside analogs.
What does this term mean?
Nucleoside means it's a
nuclear base plus a sugar.
There's no phosphates.
Because, remember,
there's an s there.
And it's an analog meaning it's
not one of the native ones,
but it--
that looks good.
AUDIENCE: I'm looking
for [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: OK.
I'll grab her.
And you get the bag.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So it's a nucleoside
analog meaning
it isn't the
standard nucleosides
that you put into your DNA.
And the most critical first line
actually became azidothymidine.
So look, that's the thymide
nuclear base, hits a sugar,
but it's different from
the regular ribose that's
either in RNA or DNA.
And it's two deoxys so it looks
more like a DNA building block.
But check it out.
On the three prime
site, there is azide.
What do you think
this thing does?
Or have I already told you?
Yeah.
What do you think
this thing does
to stop the virus marching
forward and turning
its RNA into a DNA copy?
Can it polymerase?
No.
So what do you think?
So what how does it work?
AUDIENCE: It blocks [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yeah.
Yeah.
It just grinds to a
halt. What technology
does this remind you of?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The sequencing
with the [INAUDIBLE]..
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
So it's really cool.
I mean, we're using
something like this
for sequencing blocking the
chain growth to get pieces
so we can tell the
sequence, but this
is a very viable drug for
reverse transcriptase for kind
of similar reasons, because
it stops translation.
It stops polymerization.
Now, there's one
important thing that I
need to tell you about this AZT,
as it's termed, azidothymidine.
AZT is what is known in
the industry as a prodrug.
It's not the actual drug.
Why is it a prodrug?
What has to happen
to it to be useful?
Why is it handy
to have a prodrug?
I know there's a lot
of questions there,
but they all kind
of tie together.
So it's a prodrug.
It can get into cells, right?
What has to happen to it for
it to be useful in inhibiting
reverse transcriptase?
Because it won't do
it all on its own.
Look at that structure.
There's something missing
in that structure.
What are the building
blocks in the polymerases?
Are they nucleosides?
No.
Up there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yes, exactly.
So you have to convert
this neutral molecule that
can sneak into a cell by kinases
that put phosphate groups
onto that molecule.
So that that molecule can get
engaged in polymerization,
you can put one nucleotide
onto a growing strand,
but then it can't go any further
because of that azido group
at 3, which would be the
normal place you grow.
So prodrug strategies
are very useful.
It's a way of having drugs
that aren't quite drugs yet
but they become drugs once
they are at their location.
It's not handy to use the
triphosphate of AZT as a drug,
because it can't
get in the cell.
So we deliver a cellulary
available molecule.
We let the promiscuous
enzymes in the cell
convert it to a triphosphate.
And then it becomes a
real drug, a mature drug.
So I think that's a
very important thing
about these types of
therapeutic agents.
And what I want you to know
is that many, many viruses
are treated with nucleoside
analogs performing
similar sorts of things.
But in some cases, there's a lot
of different tailoring goes on
with the nucleoside analog.
It doesn't always work to
have the azide at C3 prime.
Some of these features
don't always work.
So these have to be
tailored in different ways
to target different viruses.
Because in this case, AZT
hits reverse transcriptase.
But there may be a different
flavor of polymerase enzyme
that you need to inhibit
in other organisms.
So it's a lot, lot,
lot of options.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does it
only affect RT?
Or could there be side
effects of the cell,
like an old using
it by accident?
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
There can be, but I
think the most important thing
is that RT is very promiscuous.
So it's much more likely to
pop this building block in.
And that doesn't
have the mechanisms
to reverse that reaction, all
of the clean up that gets done
with normal DNA polymerase.
So our DNA polymerase is
going to be a lot more tuned
up to avoid these mistakes.
But the viral
reverse transcriptase
just churn through in making it.
So we're protected by our own
proofreading and other types
of mechanisms to avoid it
really messing up replication.
But that's a very good point.
OK.
So remember the central dogma.
And this is why this
process confounds that.
And that's azidothymidine.
And we've already
discussed that.
So the next enzyme that became
quite an important target,
because it was a new
target, was integrase.
So I will tell you, though,
that reverse transcriptase
inhibitors like AZT
were used early on,
but people with the virus
rapidly developed resistance
to that therapeutic agent.
It was one enzyme that was
just mutating like crazy.
And the organism could
slip through that net.
So the development
of therapeutic agents
didn't stop with AZT.
It was, like, we need to
hit other targets for us
to have a therapeutically
viable combination of therapies
that can really stop
this virus effectively.
So a next enzyme that was
targeted is integrase.
So this is the one that's
been targeted most recently.
And there are currently
several integrase inhibitors.
Integrase is a
fascinating enzyme
because it really is the
enzyme that actually stitches
that piece of viral DNA
right into the human genome
just so it's able to be
replicated, transcribed,
and translated at any time.
So integrase has been targeted.
It was a tricky target to hit.
But as you can see with
several of these drugs,
they are successful drugs.
One thing I want to
remind you about,
a lot of the names
of the agents,
if you see A-V-I-R within the
name of a therapeutic agent,
it means it's an antiviral.
So that's a clue that
all of these compounds
are given names--
raltegravir, blah.
I don't know who comes up with
these names, but nevertheless,
they're all names
that end in A-V-I-R.
So if you see a medicine
and it ends in A-V-I-R,
it's an antiviral agent.
Now, the last of the
really fascinating enzymes
that was targeted
is the HIV protease,
because the HIV protease
is very, very different
from many proteases
in mammalian biology.
It's a simple dimeric structure.
So it has quaternary structure.
It has two monomers that
are 99 amino acids each.
And each monomer
contributes an aspartic acid
to an active site.
And those are involved
in the mechanism.
And what generally happens when
substrates or inhibitors bind
is these two flaps--
one of them I've
shown you in magenta--
close down and close
up the active site.
And ritonavir was one of the
first generation protease
inhibitors that sat
in the place where
the substrate would normally
sit in the HIV protease.
And remember that
the HIV protease
is critical for
maturity of the virus
because it chops
up the polyprotein
into the necessary enzymes.
They can't be functional
enzymes in the polyprotein.
They have to cut up into
the appropriate pieces.
So the HIV protease had
unusual specificity.
And as soon as it was discovered
and structurally characterized,
every major pharmaceutical
company jumped on-- this was
in the late '80s--
to make successful
protease inhibitors that
just got better and better.
Ritonavir is an example
of first generation,
but I think now we're on third
generation-type inhibitors
which are just a better
and better and much
more selective and specific
for the HIV protease.
And because they're
much more potent,
instead of needing grams
and grams of an inhibitor,
you can get away with
milligrams of inhibitor,
which made the therapeutic
dosing for HIV much more
palatable is sort
of a good word.
Because when you have a very
promiscuous protease inhibitor,
like the early ones
that were discovered,
they mess up your entire
GI because your GI
runs on proteases
that digest your food.
So the original, the
early protease inhibitors
had a lot of side effects.
The most modern third
generation are very viable.
And this just shows
you what other topic I
want to hit on next is here's
the green and cyan two monomer
units of HIV protease.
In yellow is an
inhibitor that is bound.
And just on one monomer
of the two monomers,
I've highlighted, in red,
different resistance sites.
So when any of
those sites mutates,
the protease stops being
inhibited by the HIV protease
inhibitors.
Because you want
to think about it,
one mutation in one
subunit, actually,
will have a corresponding
mutation in the partner subunit
that is in the dimer.
So each mutation ends
up being two mutations
in the full enzyme that
has quaternary restructure.
So these are major.
They go all the way out to
the outer parts of the enzyme.
It's not just around
the active site.
It's just all over the enzyme
you can get mutations that
stop the typical drugs that
are targeted at the protease's
binding
So here I just
show you these are
data that show for
the protease and
for the reverse transcriptase.
Within the length
of the protease,
for example, there's
mutations all the way along.
I don't know why this is 101.
The numbering system is a little
different in some variants.
But you can see which mutations
will add to drug resistance.
And there's a similar picture
here for reverse transcriptase.
OK?
So this is a very serious issue.
So now I'm going to give
you a little break here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So this is HIV.
It's a typical
retrovirus, meaning
that it has an outer envelope.
And in the center, it
has two copies of RNA,
as well as an
enzyme here in blue
that's reverse transcriptase,
which will ultimately
turn that RNA into DNA.
The virus itself, with
this outer envelope
PROTEIN actually directly
infects T-helper cells.
The way that it does this is
that as it comes up to the cell
surface, it uses receptors
that are on T-helper cells
and exclusive to T-helper cells,
which are CD4 molecule which
really defines T-helper cells.
It's a surface receptor that
binds to the envelope protein.
That causes a
conformational change
and allows a second receptor
to grab hold of the envelope.
This is the
chemokine coreceptor.
It's also called CCR5.
And we'll talk about that more.
What happens now is that the
stock of the envelope protein
pierces through from the
virus into the host cell
and starts to draw the cell
membrane and the viral membrane
together.
And what ultimately happens is
fusion of those two membranes
and the viral genetic material
is injected, essentially,
into the cell.
And the envelope protein is
left at the cell surface.
- So that's the fusion process
that's so hard to explain.
- The virus has a matrix and
a capsid protein, shown here
in green and red, that
essentially are digested
when it enters into the cell.
That releases the viral
enzymes and the viral RNA.
And here we have
reverse transcriptase,
which takes the viral RNA,
and using host nucleotides
converts that viral RNA
into a single strand of DNA.
While it does that, it
makes some random errors,
which is characteristic
of reverse transcriptase.
It has very poor
proofreading activity.
That single-stranded DNA, now,
is again reverse transcribed
into a double-stranded DNA.
At that point,
another enzyme that
has come in with the virus
in the beginning, called
integrase,
essentially grabs hold
of that double-stranded
DNA and carries it
through a nuclear pore into
the nucleus of the cell.
Within the nucleus of the cell,
it finds the host chromosome.
And basically, the
integrase enzyme,
makes a nick in the host's
DNA and allows for HIV
to insert itself into
the host chromosome.
And that right there is what
establishes lifelong infection.
Now, RNA polymerase comes along
and makes its messenger RNA.
- That's the host polymerase,
it's just back to normal now.
- Those messenger RNAs encode
for different viral proteins.
They end up associating
with ribosomes
at the surface of the rough
endoplasmic reticulum.
And here is a piece
of mRNA that's
making envelope protein
which is directly produced
into the endoplasmic reticulum.
And its shuttled, then, through
the endoplasmic reticulum
and taken to the cell surface,
where, at the cell surface,
it becomes embedded in
the cellular membrane.
And at this point, coalescing
with other envelope proteins
that have been produced
you have this cluster
of envelope proteins now on the
surface of this infected cell.
At the same time, there
are other messenger RNAs
that are being produced
that allow for translation
of other viral proteins.
So here are additional
viral proteins being made
which are going to
be used to make up
the key components that
the virus, ultimately,
is going to need.
These are transported
again to the cell surface,
to the area where these
envelope proteins are.
And a strand of RNA, as
well as some of the enzymes
are part of that complex.
This then buds off at the
cell surface at this point,
but it's still not
a mature virion
because the polyprotein chain
needs to still be digested
into its component parts.
That's done by an
enzyme called protease.
Protease breaks up
those polyprotein chains
and, ultimately, allows for
them to coalesce and form
the mature structures that
make up the final virion.
And now you have a
mature infectious virion
that can go on now to
infect other cells.
Once that happens, now, the cell
can produce tons of viruses.
And this is really what, then,
keeps the whole process going.
[END PLAYBACK]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: OK.
All right.
So I have gone
monstrously long on HIV.
So sadly, I cannot
get you to Ebola.
But I'll post those
slides anyway.
This question just speaks
to combination therapies.
So combination therapies
are very, very important,
particularly in cases
where resistance
to individual therapeutic agents
against an individual target
can happen.
So HIV mutates its proteins
very, very rapidly.
But the likelihood that
it will simultaneously
mutate two targets in
one cell is much lower.
So combination
therapies basically
are there to avoid
drug resistance that
occurs, usually, because
of the high mutation rate,
not because one drug has
a short half life, not
so that multiple
strains can be targeted,
or to decrease the
number of side effects.
Obviously, combination therapies
give you more side effects,
but they are really important
in mitigating the disease.
So I was going to talk to you
about vaccine development,
but I will discuss this
with Professor Martin
to see if he wants
to take that over.
But I want to leave you
with one last thing.
OK.
Three small points.
On next Wednesday, this
is Fred Flintstone.
I tend to channel Fred
Flintstone because he
wears this nice blue scarf.
Next Wednesday is the
last of the classes.
We've got some good
stuff lined up for you.
We're going to have
the topoisomerase demo
from some people who
submitted a topo demo for us.
And then we're going
to do 7.016 Jeopardy.
Now, don't think this
is going to be cheesy.
It's going to be tough.
And it's going to be fun.
And we're all going
to be involved.
Professor Martin and
I will be the hosts.
He's promised to dress up.
Ha ha ha.
Jackie will help
me run the program,
because it's in a
real Jeopardy program.
And Hannah and David
will keep scores.
And we'd like to encourage you
who come to be in teams of two.
Otherwise, there will
be kind of a lot of you.
So if when you come in, if you
sit on that side of the room,
put your two names
on these boards.
And if you're on the other
side, put them on these boards
because Hannah and David will
be posted there to keep score.
And we will muster up some
small prize for the winner here.
So, yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Will this
count as the final?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: No.
That would be a heck of
an incentive, wouldn't it?
What this will do
for you is actually
kind of help you
refresh a lot of things,
maybe identify blind spots.
It was worth asking.
It was a good question, yeah.
So I'll post the questions
afterwards as well.
So you'll be able
to kind of say, guy,
I don't know what this
question was about at all.
And you can go and review
a little of the material.
Nice try, though.
Oh, and there was
one other thing.
I just want to remind you
that a vote is a vote.
This is a democratic society.
So you should please take time
to fill in the evaluations
on the course.
OK.